зневажання до абітурієнта небо поспішають і в
нас все і ти ж злочинної компанії
розрахунку на це своєму жив і гості
конкурс на ситуацію на таксі менше
спеціальностях також вищих та нижчих
вище від початкового закладок щепотин
натиснули ти про подали заявку це атому
поспішають і на квадрі в нашій ти ж годині
для подачі документів ми в принципі
за раз у роті напідпитку до неї
конкурсна ситуація конкурс на ситуацію
і кинули руки можна піддавайтеся а на
ресурсі вступить в окунем ж ви монтажу
це все до неї там їх можна полірувати
куди ви дамо цьому в принципі в роті не
поспіш аль потраплю в цей закон курс на
ситуацію та астані заявок удава тому що
чітким розумінням вдома я до її конкурсу
ситуацію не було проходити в цьому
скосу ватопеда купувати ще частіше
чуються я намажу його доступний на душу
термін подання документі у нас завищується
давати батьком посмішками то чи тут ще ти
чекай до завершення подання документів
просто нема поспішають еспада ним за те
щоб потім на цьому вдалося з косого
цією піцею вона